one of the many things i loved about
this movie is it's so ambitious and i
know you guys didn't make this on some
crazy budget so i just want to know how
the f did you pull this off
i mean i think that our whole careers uh
we we have after effects and scrappiness
to thank you know we we came up in music
videos pitching ideas that sounded
expensive and saying you know we have a
plan for how to do this uh with our
group of friends that you know won't
break the bank um
yeah i feel like he came from a world of
improv and theater and i came from a
world of animation and i think with
those two um tool sets in their back
pockets like we can be we can be
flexible when we need to be but we can
plan ahead and know exactly what we want
because you know that's the kind of
efficiency that you're going to need for
a lower budget movie to pull off
something like this and so i think we
have a unique
process that um you know makes it so
that we can make
things that are really ambitious um
while also this is important while not
exploiting anyone you know i think
everyone got paid really well in this
movie and it wasn't about how many
people it was about playing the right
people yeah i'm so curious so the russo
brothers produced this how exactly did
they get involved in this i think
there's like a a
subconscious directing duo club that
we've all been forming where we're like
you're a duo let's let's get dinner and
talk about how to duo um so we we met
them back uh in 2016 after making swiss
army man and uh
and they you know came on board to help
us develop the script before um we then
partnered with a24 um and we got to kind
of pick their brains about their process
and uh
and and that was uh helpful because we
kind of
got to hear what
what worked for them what didn't and and
then invent something that made sense
for us
uh uh and i want to make sure i'm
pronouncing it right but i believe it's
key
um yes yeah i just wanted to make sure
um is so good in this
and his chemistry with michelle is off
the charts when did you realize oh my
god we this is like we've bottled like
gold with this
yeah
i i wish yeah uh
the first time he came into an audition
room we thought
i thought maybe he was in character as a
bit you know because he's just actually
so
bubbly and enthusiastic and sweet which
is
how the character of weymouth is written
um
uh
but that's just what he's like and
and then he just got better and better
every time we worked on a scene and he
worked his butt off
to create the performance that you know
made it to the final
film um yeah because his his character
that that's the heart of the movie and
we knew if we didn't nail some of those
scenes sequences with him um
you know the rest of the movie might not
have worked and so we were so grateful
that um he
came back to acting for this movie you
know which was amazing but then also so
grateful that he was so passionate about
it that he made it his number one
priority and you can see it he he put
his uh he put 110 into every single
performance every single moment of that
of that performance
and i guess the last ingredient is
michelle is such a generous scene
partner you know and and
she welcomed him back into cinema uh
with with open arms and i think they had
a lot of fun together yeah i'm just
about out of time but i love talking to
directors about the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
so can you guys talk a little bit about
the challenges of editing this movie and
maybe some of the obstacles you had to
overcome
yeah uh it wasn't an easy edit uh but
luckily our assistant editors zoe and
ashish made it a lot easier to edit
during a pandemic um
and the pandemic also afforded us
more time than we thought we were gonna
have and so
with our editor paul rogers we kind of
chipped away and polished and shaped the
movie for over a year
um yeah and i think the hardest thing
about this movie is is we broke so many
rules of cinema of like what you're
supposed to be doing and so when you're
in this unknown territory it's all about
iteration it's all about trying things
out a b testing it's
you know even though it's it's chaotic
and feels like this organic artists um
kind of uh of experiments like we we
used you know science and data to really
just like engineer this thing like i've
been saying that this is engineered
movie that's kind of like impossible
burgers you know it's like uh
it tastes like a superhero movie and it
it it feels like a blockbuster but at
its core it's an indie movie it's
actually made of vegetables it's
actually it's actually a really
beautiful personal drama yeah exactly so
um it the the edit was really like it
was a process of just trying different
things out until it clicked until it
worked i got to stop listen i had a
thousand other questions i just want to
say again congrats loved it i hope it's
a huge hit for you guys i hope so too
thank you thank you so much for writing
about us or talking about us yeah
of course thank you